supreme court justice ruth bader  ginsburg has died  the pioneering legal and feminist icon  was 87.  the supreme court said she was  surrounded by her family at her home in  washington d.c  she died due to complications of  metastatic pancreatic cancer days before  her death  ginsburg dictated this message to her  granddaughter clara  spara my most fervent wish is that i  will not be replaced until a new  president is installed  ginsburg served more than 27 years on  the supreme court and  her historic journey was profiled in the  documentary  rbg let's topple the whole damn system  of discrimination  in 2018 felicity jones portrayed  ginsburg in the movie on the basis of  sex ruth bader ginsburg is someone who  has never given up she is a fighter  continually the  the obstacles have always been against  her she came from very modest  a very modest background she didn't have  any connections in the law and through  her sheer hard work she's achieved such  greatness